So here we are.
Well,
so I made a case tonight.
I'll go over it.
What's the case?
The postmodernist are wrong.
They're philosophically naive.
They're right about an infinite number of interpretations and wrong about a
finite number of viable interpretations and that's like that's,
that's death.
That's the end of postmodern is theory and that's not the only way in which
they're wrong.
They're wrong in a bunch of other ways,
but they're more subsidiary.
The Marxists,
they're not just wrong,
they're wrong and murderous or wrong,
murderous and genocidal.
Unless you think murderers and genocidal doesn't mean wrong and you,
you can think that there's lots of would be revolutionaries who would be happy
to have blood running in the street if they had their chance for revenge and the
opportunity to move up the hierarchy of tyranny so you can,
you don't have to think that murder and genocide is wrong,
especially if the right people are murdered in genocide,
right?
That's actually part of it,
part of the whole equation.
But if you're willing to think that murder and genocide on a mass scale across
many cultures,
over many decades is wrong,
then Marxism is wrong.
And the postmodernist don't get to just come along.
And a dog Marxism as a matter of sleight of hand because they're Marx's theory
didn't work out and they figured out a rationalization.
They don't get to get away with that because it's too dangerous.
It's too dangerous to the rest of us,
and we don't.
And it isn't necessary for us who are trying with the small part of our hearts
that might be oriented towards the good to allow people who are manipulating us
with historical ignorance and philosophical sleight of hand to render us so God
damn guilty about what our ancestors may or may not have done.
So that we allow our shame and our guilt to be,
to be used as tools to manipulate us into accepting a future that we do not want
to have.
And that's that
[inaudible].